it's a smart summon and soon auto park
takes on the full beautiful mess of
parking lots and their human human
nonverbal communication I think it has
actually the potential to have a
profound impact in changing how our
civilization looks at AI in robotics
because this is the first time human
beings people that don't own a test to
me I've never seen it that's what I
heard about a Tesla get to watch
hundreds of thousands of cars without a
driver
yeah do you see it this way almost like
an education tool for the world about AI
do you feel the burden of that the
excitement of that or do you just think
it's a smart parking feature I do think
you are getting at something important
which is most people have never really
seen a robot or and what what is the car
there's autonomous it's a four wheeled
robot yeah it communicates a certain
sort of message with everything from
safety to the possibility of what AI
could bring his current limitations its
current challenges its what's possible
do you feel the burden of that almost
like a communicator educator to the
world about AI we're just really trying
to make people's lives easier with
autonomy but now that you mention it I
think it will be an eye-opener to people
about robotics because they've really
never seen most people never seen a
robot and are hundreds of thousands of
Tesla's won't be long before there's a
million of them that have autonomous
capability and the drive without a
person in it and you use you can see the
kind of evolution of the cars
personality and and thinking with each
iteration of of autopilot you can see
it's it's uncertain about this or it
gets it but now it's more certain now
now it's moving in a slightly different
way like I can tell immediately if a car
is on tells autopilot because got just
little nuances of movement it just moves
in a slightly different way it will
cause an intense ODA path for example on
the highway are far more precise about
being in the center of the lane than a
person if you drive down the highway and
look at how at where cars are the human
driven cars are in within their lane
they're like
of course they're like moving all over
the place car on autopilot
dead center
you